[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لقد ذهبنا على القيام بذلك منذ 30 عاما
ستطلق منظمتنا برامج اخرى وستستمر في
تنفيذ برامجها الحاليه على الارض لسد
حاجات الناس لقد وفرنا مراكز عنايه من
السرطان عندما لم تكن الضفه الغربيه تتوفر
ولو على مركز وحيدا من هذا النوع لقد
بنينا اثنين بفضل تبرعات من مختلف انحاء
العالم بنينا مراكز عنايه مركزه ومراكز
قلب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سنستمر في تنميه وتوسيع برامجنا ومساعده
شرائح اكثر من الاطفال وانقاذ مزيدا من
الحوات ونقل مزيدا من الاطفال للخارج
للعلاج بتوحيد جهد الناس فعندما يكون طفل
بحاجه الى المساعده لا يوجد اي معنى لان
تكون فلسطينيا او امريكيا او اماراتيا نحن
كلنا بشر لا يوجد مسلم او مسيحي عندما
يكون هناك طفل يتالم بحاجه الى عمليه
جراحيه او تدخل طبي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]